دع الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان كلا من
روسيا واوكرانيا للعوده الى مباحثات
السلام لانهاء الحرب واضاف اردوغان خلال
مؤتمر صحفي مع نظير الاوكراني
في اسطنبول اضاف ان اوكرانيا تستحق ان
تكون عضوا في حلف الناتو من جهته قال
الرئيس الاوكرانيين بلاده ستستعيد السيطره
على شبه جزيره القرم واضاف ان بلاده
منفتحه على التعاون مع تركيا في مجالات
التصنيع العسكري وانتاج الطائرات المسيره
وغيرها
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان اوكرانيا
غير مستعده الان للانضمام لعضويه حلف
الناتو ومن الحكمه تاجيل النقاش حول هذا
الامر الى ما بعد انتهاء الحرب واضاف بيدا
في لقاء مع شبكه سي ان ان الاخباريه
الامريكيه انضمام كييفل الان سيجعل الحلف
في حاله حرب مباشره مع روسيا
لا اعتقد ان الاوكرانيين مستعدون للانضمام
الى عضويه النيتو ولا اعتقد ان هناك
اجماعا في دول الحلف حول ضم اوكرانيا الى
عضويته ونحن في خضم الحرب فان فعلنا ذلك
الان فسنكون ملزمين بالدفاع عن كل شبر من
اراضي الحلف وبالتالي سنكون جميعا في حاله
حرب مع روسيا لذلك اعتقد انه يتعين علينا
رسم مسار عقلاني لاوكرانيا لتكون مؤهله
للانضمام للنيتو